hi thank you for joining me today
my name is jamie york and i'm an
applications chemist at restek in the lc
department
today i'll be talking about approaching
cannabis potency testing method
development
but the main focus on lc uv
instrumentation
first some presentation objectives
before we get started
first i'll give an overview over the
exciting new developments in the
legalization
for cannabis in the united states and
then we'll move on to
cannabis flower samples and how we can
prepare them and do
the subsequent potency testing and then
we'll talk a little bit about
concentrates thc isomers and how we can
streamline potency testing
and then i'll give a general overview of
sample preparation techniques
and then we'll talk about some samples
that rely heavily on sample preparation
which are cbd
infused lotion balms and creams and the
full method development for this
and the subsequent potency testing
before we jump into the analysis of
these different cannabis samples
i want to touch on some exciting
developments in the legalization of
cannabis
in the united states so as of 2020
five additional states have been added
to the list of recreational legalization
these states include new jersey vermont
arizona
south dakota and montana so the more
states that legalize the use of
cannabis really allows for more
opportunities for entrepreneurs to
invest
more testing labs are going to open
there's really going to be more
acceptance in the industry
hopefully all this is leading to a path
forward for testing standardization
and really a very exciting future for
the industry
now let's jump into the analytical
portion of this presentation
uh cannabis flower samples are obviously
the
bread and butter of the industry it's
extremely important to be able to
quantitate cannabinoid contents in these
samples with the utmost confidence
so really this is a routine easy
straightforward analysis that potency
testing labs do
every day kind of everybody has their
own flavor
or way to go about doing it so for our
analysis we use 200 milligrams of ground
flour
this could be scaled up and that really
depends on the requirements for your
state
so this is measured out into a 50
milliliter centrifuge tube
uh 10 milliliters of isopropyl alcohol
is added
again you know there's other extraction
solvents that can be used for this
i've seen you know a mixture of methanol
water ethanol
there's really a lot of different ways
to go about preparing these samples
so then the sample is vortexed for five
seconds and sonicated for five minutes
this is then repeated two additional
times for a total of three cycles
the sample is in centrifuge for five
minutes
an aliquot of the supernatant is taken
and diluted tenfold with solvent
and then the sample is vortexed and
transferred to a filter vial
and then injected onto the instrument
the subsequent analysis of these samples
is very straightforward
the top chromatogram is representative
of a cannabis flower sample
that was prepared by the previous method
and the bottom chromatogram is
representative
of a 16 cannabinoid standard analyzed in
solvent
just to confirm the retention times of
the real sample's peaks
both methods were analyzed on a raptor
arc 18
150 by 4.6 millimeter column
using an isocratic method the isochronic
method conditions are
25 water containing 5 millimolar
ammonium formate
0.1 percent formic acid and 75
acetonitrile with 0.1
formic acid detector used for this
is a uv vis at 228 nanometers and the
overall analysis time is 9 minutes
but what about new cannabinoids there's
over 150 phytocannabinoids that have
been discovered thus far
two of the most recent discoveries
include thcp
and cbdp which were discovered last year
the difference between their structures
and their parent structures
is the number of carbons contained on
the side chain
so here i have an example of a thc
structure
up top and so you can see this has five
carbons on that side chain
and the bottom structure is thcp and
this has seven carbons
so this actually means that as thcp has
a stronger affinity for the cb1 receptor
this actually results in thcp being 33
times stronger than thc
so you can see how this is a really
exciting discovery for the industry
but how can we go about detecting these
compounds
we were able to develop three different
methods monitoring 21 cannabinoids
including both cbdp and thcp to meet
various lab's needs
all three of these methods use the same
mobile phase conditions outlined in the
previous method
using an isocratic conditions and a
uv-vis detector
so all three methods use the raptor arc
18 phase
which is robust and perfect for high
throughput applications
the arc 18 is not a standard c18
it's hysterically 100 c18 and offers
similar but some unique selectivity
so the top method uses a 150 by 4.6
millimeter column dimension
and a 1.5 mil per minute flow rate
the overall run time is 12 minutes and
this is a great
rugged reliable choice the column
dimension
actually makes it so it's transferable
to older instrumentations that may not
be
optimized to control extra column
volumes
the middle chromatogram uses a 150 by
2.1 millimeter column dimension
and a 0.4 mil per minute flow rate
the overall run time for this method is
10 minutes cutting down
on the overall analysis time from the
previous method
it also uses significantly less solvent
and less sample
and we refer to this method as our
solvent saving method
so the bottom chromatogram uses a 100 by
3 millimeter column dimension
and a 1.8 micron particle with a flow
rate of 1 mil per minute
the overall analysis time for this is
five minutes making it the most
rapid of the three methods so some
considerations need to be taken
into your system's extra column volume
before choosing the
middle or bottom column dimensions
now let's move on to another sample type
concentrates
concentrates come in many different
forms consistencies and compositions
depending on how they're prepared it
kind of depends on what will be found in
the final product
so it could be prepared dry water-based
solvent-based or co2
so the two most common classes that are
found in concentrates
are cannabinoids which are potency
tested by lc
and terpenes which are typically
monitored by gc analysis
uh so since this is mainly an lcuv uh
presentation we're just gonna stick to
talking about the cannabinoids of these
so for sample preparation it's pretty
straightforward 20 milligrams of
concentrate
is measured out into a 50 milliliter
centrifuge tube
10 milliliters of ethanol is added the
sample is then vortexed for 5 seconds
and sonicated for five minutes
this cycle is repeated two additional
times for a total of three cycles
then the sample is centrifuged and an
aliquot of the supernatant is taken and
diluted 50-fold with solvent
and then the sample is vortexed and
filtered using a filter vial
since we're discussing concentrate
samples let's touch a bit on thc
isomers there's a total of 30 different
isomeric forms of thc that have been
discovered thus far
i've listed a few up here of current
interest
of course everyone knows delta 9 thc
it's the main
psychoactive component found in cannabis
delta 8 thc is another analog and is
also psychoactive
but it's potentially less potent the
initial passing of the farm bill
in united states didn't initially
include language for delta athc
allowed it to kind of fly under the
radar but it's since become illegal
to convert cbd to delta 8 thc in several
states
xothc is typically not found naturally
in cannabis but it could potentially be
an indication of synthetic thc
or the byproduct of manufacturing
processes of concentrate preparations
delta 10 thc is becoming a hot topic and
is thought to not have psychoactive
effects
but testing's somewhat limited and it
could have diluted psychoactive effects
so here a method has been developed to
baseline separate these four thc
isomers of interest in just under four
minutes
so this method uses a raptor
fluorophenyl 100 by three millimeter
column
um the flow rate for this is point eight
milliliters per minute with an isocratic
mobile phase conditions consisting of a
five millimolar ammonium formate plus
0.1
formic acid in water and for our organic
mobile phase 0.1 percent formic acid
in methanol so by using this method to
look at thc concentrates
uh labs can cut back on instrument time
due to the rapid analysis
but also save money by using methanol as
opposed to acetonitrile
some cannabis matrices rely on sample
preparation more so than
others there's so many different things
that cannabis has been added to
that are now available on the market
name a personal care product or type of
edible
and i bet you can find it infused with
cannabinoids
this makes it difficult for analytical
chemists to come up with methods for
each type of matrix
but it's important to remember all the
tools available in your analytical
toolbox
some of the available options for
cleaning up a matrix include things like
solid phase extraction or spe
centrifuging filtration
liquid liquid extraction catchers
dispersed solid phase extraction or dspe
and precipitation if you're wanting to
look at low levels of compounds
maybe something like pesticides or
mycotoxins in cannabis flower
you could opt for a pre-concentration
step like spe
to reach your desired limits of
detection
and then another tool that you could
choose maybe if you found a wonderful
extraction solvent for your analytes of
interest
but it's not compatible with your lc
mobile phases you can always dry down
the sample and reconstitute it with a
more compatible solvent
one set of samples that relies heavily
on sample preparation
are cbd infused lotion bombs and creams
these samples contain many different
components
i've listed a few of the most abundant
ingredients up here for each sample type
but what really makes these challenging
is that even you know lotion to lotion
sample or bondo bomb sample
the ingredients can vary wildly and so
it really makes it challenging to come
up with a method to be inclusive
for all of these types of matrices
so just to name a few of the top
ingredients of some of the samples we
looked at
for lotions they had things like aloe
vera
water shea butter fatty acids plant
extracts fragrances
and many many more bombs bombs are going
to be
contained beeswax that's kind of what
gives it that waxy consistency
of course they have many other
ingredients in there fatty acids esters
of fatty acids triglycerides
a lot of them have menthol have cream
ingredients so these are going to have
less water than lotions and typically be
thicker
they'll have emulsifiers glycerides
fatty acids
among other things so when developing a
method
for these types of samples it's
important to find a balance between the
solubility of
the matrix and the extractability of
your analytes of interest
so now we're going to do a deep dive
into the method development
for these sample sets so the overall
goal of these experiments was first to
find a universal extraction solvent
for all lotion bombs and creams that are
infused with cbd
so we want to simplify the sample
preparation and make sure
any steps that we put into the sample
preparation procedure
have purpose and we're not doing them
for too long or too short
then we want to develop a method to
accurately quantitate cbd
in these samples and then lastly we want
to make sure that we're producing
a clean extract and that this extract
won't
dirty the instrument or the column over
time
so a jumping off point for these samples
we have a starting sample preparation
procedure and some starting instrument
conditions
so to start off with the sample prep a
half of a gram of sample was added to a
50 milliliter centrifuge tube
and uh five milliliters of methyl
tert-butyl ether was
added and then 50 microliters of the
sample
after it was vortex 50 microliters of
the sample was transferred to
a centrifuge tube and the solvent was
dried off
and then the sample was reconstituted
with solvent and vortexed
and then centrifuged for 30 minutes at 4
degrees celsius
this was transferred to an lc vial and
injected onto the instrument
so for the instrument conditions again
we're using a raptor arc 18 column the
150 by 4.6 millimeter dimension
we're using a guard column cartridge for
this just to help protect our analytical
column
ensure uh that we are getting the full
use out of this column's lifetime
the overall flow rate of this is 1.5
milliliters per minute
and we're using the same isocratic
mobile phase conditions as previously
outlined
so pictured here we have our lotion balm
or a cream sample dissolved in our
extraction solvent our methyl terpetyl
ether
you can see that that's not completely
soluble
just about all the samples had some type
of precipitation
or flocculation in it um the percent
recovery for the
these experiments ranged from uh 75
percent
to 95 so there is some room for
improvement here
so listed here we have our samples in
the left hand column
our experimentally calculated milligrams
of cbd per
bottle and then the standard deviation
for these experiments
the label value and our calculated
percent
difference from the label value so
highlighted in red
here i just have anything over 20
we want to stay between zero to twenty
percent four percent difference if we
can
so we have two of these uh samples one
lotion and one cream
that is above our target point
some initial solvent scouting for this
so we
wanted to find a universal solvent
that's going to dissolve
all of these different samples as much
as possible
so if they can't completely dissolve the
sample
we want as small as particles as
possible just to increase that surface
area
so a number of different solvents were
tested
these include methanol toluene hexane
ethyl acetate ipa mtbe acetone
acetonitrile and isooctane co-solvents
were also tested
this is just qualitatively seeing what
will dissolve
best ultimately we came up with a
mixture of
ipa acn and hexane to dissolve the
samples
as much as possible so down at the
bottom
in the pictures we have the mtbe samples
labeled in red
and then labeled in the white numbers is
going to be our
mixture of co-solvents so you can see
for the most part these samples are
dissolved
pretty well a lot better than with mtbe
alone
now samples 4 5 and 6 are going to be
our
bomb samples so that's likely going to
be bee's wax down at the bottom
now let's start with sample preparation
optimization
so now we're going to start off by uh
see if we can optimize the centrifuging
and winterization step
so previously we were doing this for 30
minutes
so we want to test the percent
recoveries in our new solvent
by looking at them at five minutes 10
minutes 15
and 30 of centrifuging and winterization
and then seeing if we could maybe just
do away with that stuff
altogether and just use a filter vial
with no centrifuging and no
winterization
here we have our results from those
experiments
our percent recovery on that y-axis
so we're looking for a range from 110
to 9 or 90 to 110 on that x-axis we have
each of our seven
samples that were tested and then the
key over here
uh in the lighter blue color is going to
be our original method so
our mtbe solvent uh winterizing and
centrifuging for
30 minutes and then below that is going
to be our mixture of solvents
with our various amounts of time or
completely doing away with the
centrifuging
and winterization altogether so looking
at these results
overall the mixture with the filter vial
had the best results
if you look in between the 90 to 110
uh lines here only really lotion number
one was a little bit out of range
now let's move on to the quantitation of
cbd
so just to kind of throw a little bit of
a monkey wrench into this we wanted to
add some additional cbd containing
samples
just to see how well our method worked
so we're adding four additional samples
uh two lotion samples one cream and one
balm
with varying concentrations of infused
cbd
and wildly different ingredients so
let's see how
our method that has been previously
developed holds up
so our sample prep right now is half a
gram of sample with five milliliters of
our mixture of co-solvents we vortex
that and then centrifuge for five
minutes
take an aliquot of the supernatant and
transfer that to a vial
and dry down the solvent then we
reconstitute that sample
uh with one milliliter of solvent and
use the filter vial before injecting
onto the instrument
so these are our results for our
developed method
with our co-solvents for extraction
on the left hand side this is going to
be our 11 different
samples that we have beside that is
going to be the
experimentally calculated milligrams of
cbd
per bottle and then followed by the
standard deviation
and our label value and then finally in
the right hand column is going to be our
percent difference
from the label value so anything
highlighted in red is anything
over 20 so if you look at this data
you can start to notice something
interesting so
out of the five samples that
have high percent difference from the
label value
four of these are actually bomb samples
since bombs had a large percent
difference from the label value
um we wanted to go back and reevaluate
our extraction solvent so during the
preliminary
solvent scouting we actually observed
that toluene dissolved the bomb samples
really well
and so pictured below is each of the
samples dissolved
in toluene and 4 5 6 and 11
are going to be bomb samples
so here highlighted in the blue box are
going to be our results from using
toluene as a solvent
and in this pinky purple box are going
to be our previous results
with our co-solvent mixture so
looking at this data when we look at the
percent difference value
it actually got a lot worse even
compared to
our our previous analysis using our
co-solvents
so now it's time to take kind of a new
approach to this
so instead of thinking about what's
going to completely dissolve these
samples the best
let's find something that cbd will
actually extract into
really well so we know cbd is very
soluble in methanol
so let's try using methanol as an
extraction solvent
even though in our preliminary tests we
know that it's not going to completely
dissolve the samples
and we are going to get some
flocculation
so now using methanol as our extraction
solvent
we can run through the process uh
basically weighing out our half gram
of lotion bomb or cream adding five
milliliters of
methanol i actually found a paper um
in a literature research that used uh 95
5 methanol water with 0.1 percent formic
acid
and they seem to have really good
results with this so i decided to
try that and so after adding the solvent
the sample is vortexed and centrifuged
and then an aliquot is transferred to a
vial and dried down
a one milliliter of solvent is added and
vortexed
and then it is transferred to a filter
vial before being injected onto
the instrument here we have
our experimentally determined
concentration of samples for
the methanol solvent we have our
experimentally calculated cbd
per bottle our standard deviation and
our percent
difference for the label value so we can
see this is an
improvement on some of our previous
solvents
we still have a few of our samples that
are
higher than our 20 cut off
so here i've gathered uh all of the data
for the extraction solvents that we've
used
thus far so if you remember back for
the mtbe data we only had samples one
through six when we were doing the mtbe
solvent so we don't have data for
samples eight through 11. but
all the rest of the data is compiled
here so on the
y-axis we have percent difference and on
the x-axis is each
number sample so when we look at this we
can start to see
that um you know obviously toluene was
the worst extraction solvent that we
tried
um the majority of these looked really
really bad
um but whenever you start to look at
mtbe and methanol together you can kind
of get
get to see some really good data going
on here so
uh for state ball number one mtbe looked
good
for state one number two methanol looked
good for sample number three
methanol sample four mtbe
five really could go either way uh six
mtbe looks a little bit better and then
we don't have that data for the rest of
these but methanol looked pretty good
for the majority of these except for our
sample number 10.
so between those two solvents most of
the samples could get values within a 20
difference of that label value so we
want to go through the sample
preparation procedure again
and perform it with mtbe just so we have
data for all the samples but also
perform it with
mtve methanol and a 50 50 mixture for
the extraction solvent
as this could very possibly be our
universal solvent that we're looking for
so these are our results for our
mixture of solvents our methanol mtbe at
a 50 50 mixture
so looking at this data again we have
the
sample name our experimentally
calculated cbd per bottle
standard deviation and percent
difference of label value
so lotion number one and lotion number
10 are pretty high
but the rest of this data looks is
starting to look pretty good
um unfortunately at this point sample
number six was consumed and we couldn't
replenish that sample
so we just kind of had to drop that from
the analysis
so putting all this data together um
again looking at these percent
difference graphs for each solvent
tested for each sample
again we have our percent difference on
our y-axis
and our sample number on the x-axis
um mtbe data was replaced with the most
recent of data
um whenever we went back and redid all
of that
so you can see that uh the methanol mtve
at a 5050 mixture the the green bars
are looking pretty good for the majority
of these samples really
only sample ten and one need a little
bit of work
so let's go back and optimize our sample
preparation procedure
and see if we can work with sample
number one and sample number 10
and see if we can get these samples
looking good by optimizing our procedure
so using a half gram of lotion bomb or
cream again
adding our co-solvent uh methyl terbutyl
ether methanol
mixture and then vortexing we're going
to do
a step in there where we try and
optimize
time on shaker table so after we add
everything together we're gonna do
no time on shaker table five ten or
fifteen minutes
and then we'll centrifuge it for five
minutes uh take an aliquot of the
supernatant and dry off the solvent
reconstitute it with a different solvent
and then we're going to put that
centrifuging back in and see
if that will start to help with these
two samples
so we'll test this at 0 5 and 10 minutes
before transferring an aliquot into a
filter vial
and injecting that onto the instrument
so these are the results for our
previously outlined experiments
so up top is the bar graph for lotion
number one
and at the bottom the blue one is the
bar
graph for lotion number 10. on the
y-axis is calculated milligrams of cbd
per bottle
and that green dotted line is going to
be the
actually reported value so the the value
that's on the bottle
on our x-axis in the smaller subgroup we
have
no centrifuging five minutes of
centrifuging and
ten minutes and then in the larger uh
sub
portion of the x-axis we have time on
shaker table so no shaker table
five minutes ten minutes and fifteen so
when looking at this data you can start
to see some really interesting
trends going on here so basically
time on shaker table had the most effect
with no time on shaker table having some
of the
data that was largest away from the
actually reported values so overall
centrifuging didn't have much effect
between the
the subsets whether you did no
centrifuging five minutes or ten minutes
so ultimately five minutes on the shaker
table
and no centrifuging was added to our
sample preparation procedure
so our final sample preparation
procedure for these cbd
infused lotion bombs and creams was half
a gram of sample
with five milliliters of our methyl
tert-butyl ether and methanol 50 50
mixture added
sample is vortexed and total dissolved
as much as possible
it will not dissolve all the way for
some of these samples
and then the samples are put on a shaker
table for five minutes
and centrifuged and then an aliquot is
transferred to a vial and the solvent
dried
off then the sample is reconstituted
with solvent
and filtered with a filter vial so this
used a number of sample preparation
techniques including using an extraction
solvent centrifuging drying off the
solvent and reconstituting with a
different one
and filtration
so the analysis of these samples is
pretty straightforward
raptor rkt and 150 by 4.6 millimeter
column is used
with an isocratic method and an overall
five-minute analysis time
the mobile phases include the same
isochronic mobile phases as previously
outlined for
cannabis flower it's important to always
use a guard cartridge when analyzing
real samples to help protect your
analytical column
and improve the lifetime a
representative chromatogram can be seen
for lotion
at the top a bomb sample in the middle
and a cream sample at the bottom so the
cbd is
peak is alluding a little bit after
three minutes
and the overall analysis time for these
is five minutes just to ensure that
everything is eluding off the column
from the matrix
and there's no excessive buildup
so here we have our results from our
final separate sample preparation
method so our percent recovery is
ranging
from 90 to 108 percent
and our percent difference from our
reported value
ranges from 0 to 20.
so in summary it can be beneficial when
potency testing to have
tailored methods for each type of matrix
it can cost time in the beginning to
develop these methods
but by using tailored methods for each
type of matrix
labs can really save instrument time and
ensure that the best quality data is
being obtained
it's also important to remember that
different labs have different needs
and while some labs may be most
interested in saving money on mobile
phase usage
you know others may be most interested
in shortest
methods and highest throughput of
samples
and then finally sample preparation is
an important step in the method
development process
and it's really essential for complex
matrices as we saw for
our lotion bomb and cream samples this
is going to be the key
to keeping instruments up and running
and obtaining reliable and reproducible
data
as well as maximizing the lifetime of
the analytical column
so i'd like to thank you for your time
today and for joining me
and i'd like to open it up to any
questions from the audience
um if you think of a question later feel
free to
uh send me an email i've listed my email
here on the slide